okay I believe that Bernie Sanders
should condemn the Maduro regime in
Venezuela wait don't down vote this yet
just do me the courtesy of listening to
what I have to say and watching the
video before you dislike it on YouTube
or send me angry email which I know you
will anyway okay just consider listening
to what I have to say first there's a
contingent of the audience that's going
to crush me for this story I don't care
okay I just tell it as I see it disagree
agree whatever I'm telling it to you as
I see it and in good faith with peace
and love a friend of the show bill scher
has a really good article in Politico
which we're linking to arguing that
Bernie Sanders could do away with all
confusion on this issue of his view of
Venezuela and Nicolas Maduro um and he
can do it specifically to stop
Republicans from smearing him as wanting
to make the United States like Venezuela
now we all know and by that I mean the
the core audience that has a connection
to reality we all know that when Bernie
Sanders has talked about democratic
socialism and/or social democracy he's
not talking about making the u.s. like
Venezuela he's talking about Denmark and
Sweden bill scher lays out very clearly
how the right is now using Venezuela to
smear not just actual socialism but
social democracy as well and on Monday I
talked with you about what is actually a
very old tactic smearing Social
Democrats as communists and socialists
goes back a hundred or more years at
this point and front and center right
now we have Donald Trump at the State of
the Union declaring we will never be a
socialist country we have Mike Pence
using a similar line or similar argument
and what bill scher points out in his
article is that Bernie Sanders
historically has mostly talked not about
being socialist like Venezuela and Cuba
but being socially democratic like
Denmark and Sweden which of course we
understand is not socialism social
democracy is a mixed capitalist economy
not a socialist system and I've pointed
out before Bernie's
may well sort of come from the Vermont
hippie democratic socialism school but
the policies that he's advocating for
today are 100% not socialist policies
medicare-for-all in a capitalist system
college tuition to state colleges and
universities paid for through taxation
in a capitalist system with private
property and and without socializing the
means of production business regulation
of capitalist businesses this is social
democracy it's not socialism and I've
pointed out that it's a mistake for
anyone who's a social democrat
to call themselves a Democratic
Socialist because it makes smearing them
even easier for the American right so
Bernie Sanders has a choice here and
remember I'm not giving Bernie advice on
what he should think about Venezuela
he's already told us what his view is on
Venezuela the u.s. cannot be involved in
regime change Bernie has made that clear
in Venezuela but Nicolas Maduro cannot
be supported in Venezuela and Bernie has
also made that clear Venezuela as Bernie
Sanders is clarified as bill scher
points out is an authoritarian
kleptocratic Ola gargy Bernie has
already attacked the suppression of
democracy in Venezuela Venezuela is
quickly failing multi-day blackouts
astronomical inflation all of the stuff
we've discussed but this doesn't mean
telling you Bernie has already pointed
this out Bernie's pointed out that the
crackdown on civil society that is the
Maduro regime cannot be supported so
Bernie Sanders doesn't need to come up
with any new commentary on Venezuela or
changed his view he's already said it
all he should just condemn what is going
on and say under no circumstances am I
talking about making the u.s. like
Venezuela he is against the us-led
regime change in Venezuela I'm against
us-led regime change in Venezuela
Bernie's pushing for social democracy a
well-regulated mixed economy like Sweden
or Denmark
that's what I've been talking about on
the program for years period and as bill
scher points out in his article Bernie
Sanders doesn't have to side with Trump
on this issue Bernie Sanders doesn't
even have to rack
Wanhua though as a legitimate interim
president he doesn't have to do any of
that stuff he can just say very clearly
and unequivocally I don't know why
Republicans are talking about me wanting
socialism like in Venezuela I'm running
on social democracy I'm running on the
systems that Sweden and Denmark have and
my proposals match that not what we see
in authoritarian kleptocratic paradise
Venezuela
period I hope Bernie will do it bring on
the hate I'm ready I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show
one of the day's sponsors is privacy
comm slash Pakman which is a free
service that I myself use really useful
in many different ways takes just a few
seconds to link your debit card to
privacy comm then you can create virtual
credit cards that are linked directly to
your bank account and you use those
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online which protects your actual
debit card so that it's not spread all
over the internet and one of the best
things about it is how their mobile app
and browser extensions for Chrome and
Firefox make it really easy to use let's
say for example that I'm signing up for
a David Pakman show membership in the
credit card number field I already see
the privacy com icon I just click it
choose which of my virtual credit cards
I want to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link